the expanse season 5 finale is out now
and we made a video explaining the
mysteries and character arcs of the
season
which you can watch at the link below if
you haven't already
but there's also a lot of cool stuff in
the book series that wasn't included in
season 5
like bobby surfing a missile in space
and saving the martian prime minister
for example as well as a lot of
character moments world details and
thematic stuff
so how does season 5 of the show compare
to the books and what cool bits didn't
get included
this video has info from the first five
books and novellas but no spoilers from
the later books so
it's safe if you just watch the show
each book in the expanse is told from
the point of view of a different set of
characters
so the first five books all have holden
chapters but book one
also has miller chapters book two has
avasarala and bobby and prax
book three has anna clarissa and bull
book four
elvi barcia and havelock book 5
nemesis games is the first time we get
chapters from naomi amos and alex's
point of view
in the early books amos and alex are
pretty minor characters
they're actually more fleshed out in the
tv show but in book five
each of the rosie crew go off on their
own stories and we get inside their
heads for the first time
as the worlds change dramatically around
them
season five adds plot lines about
avasarala and
drama but nemesis games is about holden
alex naomi and amos so when holden is
alone
on tycho he really struggles to cope
he needs to be around people but he's
uncomfortable with how strangers treat
him like a celebrity
so holden spends some nights in a crappy
italian restaurant drinking
mediocre margaritas and before long he
is
crying drunk on bourbon with his pants
off talking to his spaceship in the dark
being unable to help his crew when
they're in danger
is a nightmare for holden and his
emotions are all over the place
luckily monika keeps him busy in the tv
show
monica investigates a plot to steal
fred's proto-molecule
but in the book monica investigates
colony ships that have disappeared
at the ring gates in the show there's
just one ship that disappears in the
finale destroyed by mysterious aliens
but in the book there's like a dozen
civilian chips that just
disappear at first monica and holden
think this is related to marco and
juarte's black market ships
and it's only at the end of the book
they realize oh [ __ ]
aliens have been eating people this
whole time those colony ships were
destroyed by the entities in the ring
at one point monica asks holden to use
fred's proto-molecule to try to
reconnect to the consciousness of miller
and ask him what's vanishing the ships
like a seance to summon a ghost
but holden refuses so monica gets
kidnapped and in the books
it's kind of holden's fault cause holden
blabs about monica's investigation to
sakai who is secretly working for marco
so once again holden's habit of sharing
sensitive information
creates trouble as avasarala says
holden's record for blurting information
is the stuff of legend but later holden
chooses to keep it a secret the fred's
protomolecule
was stolen to prevent panic he actually
withholds information for once
so holden does learn from his mistakes
he's
changed holden and fred find monica
because monica's terminal is still
connected to a hidden camera
in the books there's an extra step here
because monika's terminal is smashed
the device still works but the screen is
shattered and scrambled into shards of
glass
so they get help from a scientist
astronomers
interpret light that reflects and
refracts around planets and stars and
stuff
so this scientist uses those same
principles to decipher the light that's
scattered by this smashed screen
creating like a digital algorithmic lens
to resolve it into a visible image and
that's how they find moniker
so it's always cool when there's some
science in the sci-fi
in the show marco's people attack taiko
station
and kill fred johnson in the book fred
does get
shot but he survives in fact he fights
back this attack
in badass fashion he toughs out the
bullet wounds coordinates a defense and
he uses this secret code that he's got
with drummer
to set an ambush on the attackers cause
this is
colonel frederick lucius johnson the
butcher of anderson station
traitor to earth he's an experienced
military tactician and he's prepared for
this kind of thing
so he fights back and survives still
marco's attack
and the rise of the free navy is a huge
blow to fred politically
it shows that fred can't control his own
base
he no longer speaks for the belt when
these radicals are in power
anderson doors tells fred to cooperate
with marco
and fred seriously considers joining
marco's side and
trying to make peace to moderate the
radicals from within
holden says it's [ __ ] for fred to
change sides again
like when he left earth to go help the
belt but fred said
he never changed sides the sides keep
changing around
him fred will join whatever faction
can do the most good but in this new
political situation
it's not obvious which faction that is
holden
argues that marco is obviously the bad
guy here and ultimately fred agrees to
go work with other sarah
earth and mars alex goes back to mars to
reconnect with his ex-wife to lissa
in the show they have a son called melis
but in the books
alex doesn't have a son as far as he
knows
avasarala once mentions that alex has a
son
that he doesn't know about which is
weird
did telyssa hide his son from him or is
the mother
some other woman the books don't say
alex helps bobby investigate the black
market martian military gear
so in the show alex talks with solvater
and babbage
but in the books alex talks to juarte
juarte appears to be just this average
military bureaucrat guy described as
likable and
competent joate tells alex that he's
aware of the black market ships and is
investigating but
is powerless to stop it it's only at the
end of the book that you realize
holy [ __ ] that duate guy was lying he
was the secret mastermind behind the
black market ships and laconia
all along so alex and bobby investigate
the missing ships on the razorback and
in the book
they also rescue the prime minister of
mars from an attack by marco
marco's plan is even more ambitious in
the books because he tries to kill the
leader of mars as well
as fred johnson and holton and earth
the martian prime minister's name is
nathan smith he's described as polite
and inoffensive and he just sort of tags
along in the back seat while alex and
bobby go and save naomi
when bobby wears her power armor she
can't fit in her seat on the razorback
so
instead she just rips out the seat and
she just stands there the whole time
bracing herself on the walls in high g
with sheer strength the razorback can't
safely get to naomi fast enough
so bobby hops on a missile and rides it
as it's fired next to naomi
and that's how they grab her in the book
but in the show
they race in on the razorback and alex
dies
of a stroke from their high g burn which
is a risk they mention in the books
but in book 5 alex doesn't die
it looks like they killed him off in the
show because the actor isn't returning
next season
maybe in the show bull will take his
place as pilot on the rosie
bull is a weird addition to the show
cause in the books he only appears in
book 3
playing a similar role to drummer in
season 3.
naomi is taken prisoner by her
emotionally manipulative
terrorist ex marco and their son phillip
and in the book she goes to a really
dark place
all the old trauma and fear and guilt
from her past comes flooding back
being around marco again makes her
question her identity
is she a prisoner a terrorist
collaborator a
mother she doesn't know which is her
real self
in her despair naomi draws strength by
thinking of
amos she asks herself what would amos do
which is funny because amos is not
exactly a model of
wisdom and good decision making but
amos's
resilience and emotional detachment is
what naomi needs to survive
this fear and trauma and at the same
time that naomi draws strength from
amos amos thinks of naomi and tries to
emulate her
in his relationship with clarissa so
it's beautiful that
even when they're a zillion miles apart
naomi and amos bond makes both of them
stronger
so marco attacks earth kills billions of
people and starts a militant belter
uprising and in the book he has more
specific
reasons for doing this because belters
are a people and a culture
adapted to space their economy is based
on mining asteroids in the belt
but now there are hundreds of new worlds
beyond the ring with resources that are
way easier to extract
on planets with free air and water so
the asteroids and stations of the belt
have
no economic future but belter's bodies
are adapted to life in that low gravity
in the book spelters look very different
to inners they're
tall and thin with big heads and weak
bones
many belters can't survive on a planet
with full gravity
like how naomi couldn't live on illus
and for the belters who can live on
planets
after a generation in gravity they
wouldn't be belters anymore
the ring is a threat to the very
existence of the belter people
so part of marco's goal is to block off
access to the ring gate
he lets duate go to laconia but he
doesn't let anyone else through
holding the solar system captive to
preserve
a future for the belt fred compares
marco to alexander the great
who defeated a persian emperor at the
battle of gorgamela
which is the title of episode 4. at
gorgamela alexander was way outnumbered
but he won because he saw an opportunity
and was brave and audacious enough to
take it
just like marco had the audacity to
defeat earth
but fred wonders if marco really is as
great as alexander or if he just thinks
he is
the book emphasizes how fake and
superficial
marco is he's really good at appearing
noble and powerful but
it's a mask and when that mask slips
naomi sees a rage-filled boy
behind it when naomi and holden reunite
at the end of the book
that's when naomi tells holden about
marco and philip
and her past for the first time when she
leaves at the start of the book
she doesn't tell holden where she's
going just that she needs to go do
something
and needs to do it herself it's
important to her that holden
respects naomi's right to fight her own
battles
and to keep her own secrets holden has
to learn that he
doesn't get to know everything and
control everything
naomi tells holden about her past when
she's ready
on her terms and that makes their bond
even stronger
after she recovers from her ordeal naomi
feels at pace
for the first time in a while amos goes
back to earth
and on the way he meets a belter couple
called django and rico
in the book these guys have a daughter
called wendy and amos makes a special
effort to protect her
and buys her an ice cream he later sees
a street kid in baltimore and wants to
help him
too amos has always had a particular
need to help
children because of how terrible his own
childhood was
amos's backstory is explored in a
novella called the churn
and the show included the basic details
that as a child
amos's name was timothy and he was
sexually exploited
in organized crime a woman called lydia
was like a mother to timothy but what
the show leaves out
is that in the churn when timothy was
about 15
he and lydia also had a sexual
relationship
it says that they weren't lovers they
weren't mother and son
they were just lydia and timothy and in
their
strange complicated relationship they
found comfort in each other in the show
amos picks up this
glazed mug which is mentioned in the
churn as a gift that eight-year-old
timothy gave lydia for her birthday
so timothy and lydia's relationship was
tender
and wrong and sweet and dark
and it made amos who he is now
after the asteroids hit the books
describe the apocalyptic
devastation of earth ash rains down
coating
everything with a layer of grey blocking
out the sun
like a funeral shroud over the planet
all the plants start dying
animals freak out all over the world
food and water runs out there's riots
and
looting the birthplace of humanity is in
its death throes
and billions die but unlike the other
characters
amos doesn't feel horror or fear of this
catastrophe
he doesn't ever worry about what he
can't control
he only thinks about how to survive in
the present
so amos and clarissa escape the pitch
and survive apocalyptic america together
amos calls clarissa peaches because in
book 3
clarissa calls herself melba and a peach
melba is a kind of dessert
so peaches he also calls clarissa little
tomato
once for some reason which is also
adorable
previously amos called anna red because
she is a redhead in the books
amos calls conocheck tiny which is
interesting because in the churn amos's
crime boss called
amos tiny so amos is a man with a fake
name
who calls others by many different names
there's a moment in the show where
clarissa mentions faking an id
and amos and eric smile at each other
because in the churn eric
created the fake id that made timothy
into amos burton
so amos and clarissa and eric find a
ship to escape
earth at lake winnipesaukee it's this
enclave where rich people have holiday
homes and the books describe how
luxurious everything is
with the mansions and boathouses and a
genetically engineered dog
and this ship called the zhongguo the
books describe
its opulent decorations in silver and
gold and velvet
it's this giant lavish totally
impractical ship
more of a statement of wealth than a
means of transport
avasarala later calls it a gaudy turd
and this highlights the inequality on
earth
we've seen that many people live in
poverty and squalor
on basic and here are these [ __ ]
with mansions that are bigger than the
housing blocks that could fit
thousands but in the end all of that
wealth
doesn't mean [ __ ] in the apocalypse and
it's the mansion's staff
along with amos and clarissa and eric
who use the ship
to escape earth amos says that in times
of conflict
human groups fracture into small hostile
tribes
everything that keeps society civilized
like laws and countries and money
are just stories and when the [ __ ] hits
the fan
those stories die and violence starts
clarissa has a more optimistic inclusive
perspective like when she makes friends
with the staff at winnipesaukee
to peacefully grow their tribe so she
tells amos that
yes peace and civilization are just
stories
but people are really good at telling
stories that can bring people back
together
in the end amos brings clarissa to join
the crew on the rosie
even though clarissa tried to kill them
all once and in the book
he physically smuggles her onto the ship
inside a crate
and clarissa pops out like a
jack-in-the-box and scares alex and it's
great so
overall season 5 is a pretty close
adaptation of nemesis games
though reading the book does add some
detail and depth
throughout all the storylines in book 5
there's a lot of
thought and reflection about aging and
change
because in nemesis games the worlds and
politics of the expanse are dramatically
shaken
heading for a radically different future
but the characters are still
so defined by their pasts [ __ ] changes
and doesn't eric says naomi thinks that
things change and they don't change back
we can't undo the damage of the past
but even when everything goes wrong and
when all
our tribes are split apart we're also
really good at telling stories
to put things back together again
thanks for watching please like and
subscribe and thank you to amazon prime
video uk
for sponsoring this video we've made
four videos for the expanse season 5
and you can watch them all at the links
below thanks to patrons jessica rose
patrick shearer damps 2002
martin shawling evan and claire marco
carron shalom
entener charles a hoom and g
cheers